virginie champetier a créé en mai
dernier l'association les petits
ateliers des benjamins entouré de cinq
contres assistantes maternelles de 15
enfants de 2 mois à 3 ans virginie rend
visite chaque vendredi aux pensionnaires
de cette maison de retraite à montigny
le bretonneux
on veut produire que du bonheur en fait
est que les enfants y trouvent leur
compte et si ces banques ont cherché des
activités qui soit bénéfique pour les
deux extrémités de la vie par exemple y
apportant a fait un loto sonore avec les
bruits des animaux donc les personnes
âgées aide les enfants à reconnaître
l'animal en fait donc ce ne sont que des
activités comme celle ci ainsi pendant
1h30 en fonte et retraité partage des
activités ludiques
gisèle 85 ans ne manque jamais une
séance
moi ça me convient beaucoup mieux que ça
fait du bien aux personnes âgées de voir
toute cette cette petite jeunesse et
tout ça c'est vrai ça mais ça redonne du
coeur avait à du baume au coeur est tous
assez bref je m'ennuie quand je le vois
pas comme je sais qu'ils viennent et que
je peux pas les voir toutes les semaines
je les attends elle a aujourd'hui
j'avais prévu je me suis bien préparé la
masse avec l'association de virginie est
les seniors sont heureux de pouvoir
passer du temps avec des enfants qui
leur rappelle leur famille c'est
important il joue via une communication
on sent que des personnes qui commencent
à s'isoler quand il voit les enfants ils
se réveillent ils discutent j'ai même le
cas d'une personne qui ne communiquait
plus et quand elle l'a vu les enfants
elle s'est mise à parler
et une fois par mois ils peuvent aussi
se mettre à chanter
l'association de virginie son petit
propose des activités chorale